[Applause]
right
excited very excited good how does it
feel to be in the airport kitchen bit
overwhelming bit overwhelming uh yeah
we're ready for it right diego how you
feeling
um shooting myself really
are you ready to wear the diners yes i
am yeah good
one of you okay is going to come out as
the f words best italian restaurant make
sure it's you
prosecco from bristol and salvos from
leeds are our top two italian contenders
here's how i found them
the f word viewers love italian food you
nominated hundreds of italian
restaurants but we can only choose two
to compete in the f-word kitchen
determined to find the very best we went
to visit your culinary heroes serving
food just like mama used to make
the search took us all over britain
from nottingham to twickenham
lesser to leeds
coventry to clapham your fingers are so
delicate oh yeah it's like you're
playing the piano we discovered
fantastic food and in some cases an
exceptional level of service
there's an ad for a handyman in the
ladies lou
i'm blocking out his number in case it's
not what it seems
after months of whittling down hundreds
of nominations we finally found two
outstanding contenders
salvos and lee's shone out
how are you i'm very good thank you very
much
welcome to salvos
like many of the best local restaurants
salvos is all about family
john and jip are brothers
their father salva started the
restaurant in 1976 and 15 years ago they
inherited the business really the
restaurant's about feeling welcome
feeling that urge to lean back in your
seat to perhaps kick your shoes off
feeling that you've arrived home and
that's what we're about showing our
passion for southern italian food and
southern italian hospitality
[Music]
delicious
every mouthful i'm tasting i'm trying to
find something negative something's
wrong with it that'd give a lot of
italian chef to run for the money in
london
trust me if we actually got through it
would be fabulous i'd be really proud
they're clearly passionate family run
which is nice authentic
simple italian cuisine done with a great
delivery of flavour so i've made my
decision
beautiful picture there who is that
that's a mum and dad in selena on the
lumbolare
i think your pair is going to be
incredibly
proud for the next round
[Music]
well done guys
i'm just so proud i just wish my dad was
here to share this moment with us
because he would have been just
searching
so salvos from leeds will be cooking the
f-word kitchen tonight and i've found
the perfect restaurant to take them on
prosecco is a tiny place in bristol but
it's already getting a big reputation
it was opened three years ago by
venetian chef diego del rey and is
hugely popular with the locals
yeah very well so this is where you're
hiding down here yeah this is my bunker
you see this is my
my kingdom
okay now you want it now you get it
while diego works his magic in the
kitchen his wife heidi holds down three
jobs she's a teacher by day charms the
front of house by night and also is a
hands-on mum
i think i'm married wonder woman
honestly because
i don't know how she does it she's
absolutely incredible first up for me
ravioli in a saffron sauce he personally
makes these raviolis himself yes
i'm keen to try diego's risotto a staple
on every italian menu but a very hard
dish to get just right
not easy cooking out of the kitchen that
small yeah it is it's always a challenge
yeah sadly the
saffron sauce was very strong i went out
of my way just to do something special
and yeah probably i cooked it up yeah
with the sauce yeah the awkward thing
for me uh right now is that this is a
a very difficult category
and sadly there's only two restaurants
that are going through
to
cook
at the f word restaurant for 50 diners
okay
and you're one of them congratulations
congratulations
thank you very much
that was one of the best risottos i've
ever tasted really oh great um
absolutely delicious i mean i i mean
seriously delicious thank you now
you've got a real test for 50 diners and
i've got every confidence in you you
could pull it off okay yeah that's
brilliant that's brilliant
congratulations that's good
diego too good looking to be a chef
and uh yeah thank god i'm not having
lunch with my wife today should go mad
for him
he really deserves
it the whole idea of searching the
country for these unsung heroes this is
why that's spot-on accurate passionate
italian cooking
so i found my top two italian
restaurants
will the f-word diners prefer prosecco's
elegance
or salvo's rustic charm
we're about to find out
hey we're going to london
now
salvador yes shake hands with prosecco
let's go
let's go may the best brigade win yes
christmas that's the end of being mating
now we'll fight like a proper kitchen so
that last dessert leaves that hot plate
don't let me down more importantly don't
let yourselves down
or your restaurants down good luck right
enough chat it's time for the starter
we're back in london at the f-word
restaurant
tonight we're going italian from nearly
700 nominations we found the f word's
best two local italian restaurants
salvos and leeds and prosecco in bristol
they're going to be serving 25 portions
of their own starters if the f-word
diners don't like it they won't pay
okay on order towers yes two spinach
ravioli two poor dessert two tart yes
chef thank you yeah the uh prosecco two
cup of really main course two venison
followed by two tarts yes
so they're underway and every single
plate they send out is crucial half the
diners will be trying salvo starter
another half proseccos
i've challenged them to cook ravioli an
italian classic that's incredibly
difficult to get right
while the brigades are preparing their
own versions here's how i do it
fresh pasta the secret behind a great
ravioli smooth silky and absolutely
delicious try the filling olive oil
butter
garlic
spinach
salt pepper
nutmeg
[Applause]
drain
chop
ricotta
lemon zest toasted pine nuts
parmesan
chill
pasta dough through the machine roll
super thin
cut
on
egg yolk fold push down and squeeze all
that air out fold
trim
now to cook the raviolis literally one
and a half minutes into the boiling
water sage butter hot pan
olive oil butter
sage
lemon juice
take the revenues out gently roll it
round the sage butter
and look delicious delicate pillows
parmesan beautiful
spinach ricotta and pineapple ravioli
with sage butter
done
now i diego jeff having been selected
the best two selling questions in the
country i know you can get every guest
out there paying for your earliest okay
make it count yeah ravioli is a simple
dish but it's the one that really tests
a chef because any flaws are immediately
obvious
both rations are cooking their own
recipes it'll be interesting to see who
comes out on top
salvos and leeds has been making pasta
for 33 years their southern italian food
is rustic and charming cooking's not a
chore cooking's a joy
salvos are keeping it simple with the
spinach and ricotta ravioli
they're making a type of pasta called
faziletti
it's hand cut and folded like a
handkerchief
it'll be set with a simple tomato sauce
which they'll be thickening with a knob
of cold butter
and uh recipe originated from where well
it's a southern recipe so uh so it's
rustic
what are you finishing it with some
fresh plum tomatoes
sauteed in a little bit of water let me
stop it you can work and talk at the
same time
i'm not a woman i can only do one thing
at once no but i'll have a bash
you don't sound that italian you got a
nice broad
yorkshire accent well i am fluent in
italian what would you say to somebody
if they thought that he wasn't italian
hi here we go
here's what i'm faced with i'm faced
with a sort of pretty boy ravioli from
milan and a rustic ravioli from leeds
but they're both very impressive pretty
boy first of all i'm from venice not
milan
[ __ ] grumpy italian scallions jesus
are you always like this no this is
nothing
diego's northern italian roots means his
food is elegant and sophisticated
might appeal to you know to not everyone
but people offset so i think we're on
something pretty much right
a fiery venetian is taking more of a
risk with his ravioli
diego is using a delicate filling of
crab garlic and potato
he's using saffron any sauce it's an
unusual taste so diego's got to get it
just right
what does it mean to win tonight
probably like
winning the champions league
you know that's that i think that would
be the feeling really
more than this brush is not good the
brush this brush you see it leaves down
this this bit of this bit of plastic you
see it's meant to be black one no would
you mean black one black hair brush you
know this one would you keep our eyes
open for you i'm not going to blame the
brush yeah diego a black brush is not
gonna make a difference yeah yeah it is
make a difference because when you find
when when when one of these hair is gone
inside i won't be able to see it no
instead of a black brush you're gonna
see it because like one one of your hair
there from seeing the [ __ ] kitchen
you cooking in bristol don't dare start
slagging off this kitchen here let's get
that right yeah okay you're right for
men that cooks have a [ __ ] cubby hole
you know you don't have a kitchen here
you have a pallet yeah no it is a palace
man i don't expect guys like you to
start complaining about a [ __ ] place
make sure you flat out of this kitchen
i want this to be the best service of
your life all four of you yes yes yes
four out of four in get full plates
how long do you go for the rubbers 30
seconds they're going to change the
sauce oh yeah just put them in the sauce
okay so you got four more rolling yes
yeah 14. i smell fantastic guys yeah
really really good
as you can see there's so much more to
italian cuisine than pizza here's one of
my all-time favorite ingredients
this is chef alu on the beautiful island
of sicily home to one of italy's most
delicious ingredients
it's octopus and for some bizarre reason
we're actually terrified of eating it
god knows why because it tastes
absolutely amazing packed full of flavor
and incredibly delicious
beneath these crystal clear waters are
hidden some of the best tasting octopus
in the world
[Music]
grew up here and is going to show me how
to catch them i'm obsessed with octopus
we've had in the restaurant for the last
10 years from a capacio to a soup
to the most amazing salad everybody
loves here
when we are at the table the octopus we
go crazy right
octopus can be tricky to catch so to
maximize our chances we're laying pots
just off the coast the more you lay the
luckier you get
so there's no
there's no bait or anything no muscles
no [ __ ] or nothing nothing at all
the octopus use the pots for shelter
i've heard they love shiny objects
yeah you're gonna put that coin in there
so i'm hoping a few quid will increase
my chances good investment good
investment that's another one
it would be all full of october if not
i'm going to dive and get my money back
fingers crossed we left our pots to do
their work but later that evening enzo
decided to show me another method of
catching the elusive sicilian octopus we
should be sleeping right now yeah we
should be about that we are not right
fishing
this is the way his father used to catch
octopus in the dead of night when they
come out to feed
right what's the process now we're gonna
look on the bottom of the sea and as
soon as we see any movement of the
octopus looking for food yeah then we're
gonna spill it
[Music]
what color are we looking for
there's some color over the rocks
finally we found one
but as i moved in for the kill the boat
hit a rock
i lost my footing and the octopus
disappeared i was gutted
i've got so close to it i could almost
taste it
my favorite sicilian octopus recipe
would have to wait
next morning following rough weather
overnight and with more bad weather
forecast i knew how to get out to my
pots fast
there's a lot bigger swell on the water
today than yesterday
so here we go yeah fingers crossed
15 or 16 octopus here's the first spot
there's anything in there [ __ ] nothing
nothing moving the coin not even the yes
there is yeah coin is in there it's the
second foot second part ah [ __ ]
it wasn't just the first two that are
empty oh come on now you understand why
they are expensive to buy octopus
we've pulled all 35 pots without one
octopus to cook with
absolutely sweet [ __ ] oh say they want
to be coke to buy you
plan b
yeah i think i've got plan b
enzo's mate had laid some pots a few
days earlier and he swore they'd be
brimming with octopus
but before we could reach them our luck
turned from bad to worse
damn this is a disaster we're caught in
a huge storm
so we're gonna head back to port
wait to the weather drops off
but the storm didn't pass
in fact the weather got even worse
but it was three days before the clouds
cleared and i could resume my octopus
hunt
they're saying in town that's one of the
worst storms in 40 years
with the sea finally calm our chances
were the best they'd ever been
how long have these pots been out here
they've been here uh nearly a week they
will be full of octopus
first one this one
nothing nothing it's been the story of
our lives for the past five days ends
are not today
that's just the beginning okay
oh my god
jesus
we'd caught it the traditional way so i
was determined to kill it the
traditional way too
how do we kill them
yeah you buy this head you what you're
going to fight inside to kill it yeah
right
oh
finally luck was on our side thank god
for that we pulled in another two
including a feisty two-pounder
getting my hands on these little suckers
has been a real battle but i got a
mouth-watering sicilian stew recipe that
i knew was going to make it all
worthwhile
five days for that baby
ready to go
now i'm gonna quickly blanch it in she
goes
lovely add seasoning and a splash of
white wine to the pan and boil for 10
minutes
time to get the octopus out
beautiful
the base of my octopus stew is fried
chilies onions and garlic
[Music]
octopus
take off the top
slice that down
then the octopus is going to start
absorbing all that wonderful sweet
flavor mixing tomatoes olives capers
anchovies parsley
fish stock and a splash of olive oil
simmer 35 to 40 minutes
i'm serving my stew to enzo's sicilian
family
a popular sicilian
they're a tough mob and if they don't
like it i might just wake up with a
horse's head in my bed here we go
[Music]
i like you very very much very very good
fantastic good tough five days however
we made it it was worth it it was worth
the test this is delicious
katie price is tonight's recipe
challenger so she doesn't get to vote
but i got my team to prepare both
starter recipes for her to try
kd nice to meet donnie looking great
enjoying your food lovely absolutely
lovely you're trying to decide which one
i prefer the first or the second yep i'm
just have to pick which one would you
prefer the crab one the crab with the
saffron not too strong no lovely
interesting good and favorite italian
what would it be do you have a local in
brighton
uh donatellos
always busy and now they've got so many
different varieties of pasta and
just different dishes is it the pasta
the soups the taglitelli the ravioli i
like taco telly carbonara with peas my
extra peas mushrooms and more cream
something you cook at home
uh i've never tried it ready no no
you're here for the rest of the
challenge excited
i am actually you could beat me well
come on a silly question did you steal
this recipe from mum when i was younger
i also used to look forward to saturday
nights watching murder she wrote blind
date with my chicken care of sweet corn
and chips
chicken kiev sweet corn and chips
fantastic really good to see you can't
wait to see in the kitchen with a
challenge
excellent enjoy your dinner
so last table chip yeah make sure that
last table goes out chris like the first
hair will you
got the palms down there ready to go
yeah maybe a few more scrapings italian
cuisine that is best yeah one southern
one northern i can't wait to hear the
feedback from the customers yeah that
means it's gonna be a close contest i'll
tell you absolutely fantastic
really good jeff chris well done adam
diego well done
i thought the uh spinach pasta was
lovely the sauce was really lovely
buttery but light i enjoyed it yeah i'll
be paying for it it was quite nice all
the ingredients and everything was very
nice um i just thought the pasta was a
bit undercooked how are the raviolis yes
they're very nice they're very nice and
that was salads yeah sort of talking
straight right yeah kind of thing you
could see
um
no
no no
something a little bit more refined not
refined diego's would be a cleaner
presentation
are you going to pay for your starter i
am going to pay for my starter glad to
hear it good to see you thank you see
you later thank you
i thought the the flavor was fantastic
overall it was a it was quite quite a
tasty dish i felt it was slightly under
seasoned it was lacking some taste in
there for me personally no i won't be
paying for the start today did you enjoy
the starter yes
it was fine i think what it did is it it
just clarified the difference between
northern italy in southern island
southern italy it's all about letting
the flavors talk to themselves northern
italian a little bit
dare i say a little bit fancy a little
bit a little bit richer flavors and
different style very very different now
the most important question are you
gonna pay for it
no no wow are you gonna pay for yours
i'm not gonna pay for mine hold on a
minute you both liked it but you're not
gonna pay for it
it's just not of the i mean i'm being
polite it's just not a good enough
monitor enjoy your main course good to
see you thank you my darling
so one wife is paying for the opposition
starter and the other isn't
right i couldn't wait to try these
and see
what they're made of
pasta's slightly bit thick there from
salvos
really good flavor sauce not too heavy
in terms of flavor rustic and somewhat
charming now proseccos we've got to try
that pasta nice and thin
pasta's cooked perfectly sauce vibrant
got that wow factor the unfortunate
thing is inside ravioli is slightly
bland you could do a touch more
seasoning what a shame
i like both dishes but some diners have
found a lot to criticize i really don't
know what the result will be
okay jb please
right okay here we go thank you okay
let's start off with
salva
the number of customers
that are happy to pay for your starter
tonight is
19 out of 25. well done congratulations
thank you so um jb these six customers
that didn't pay for their starter why um
memories in the past i was too thick did
you both roll the pasta uh i rolled it
so it may i called perhaps
i didn't get one or two lines yeah
however 19 out of 25 well done
okay prosecco for your starter out of 25
starters
the amount willing to pay for your
starter is
15 out of 25.
hey
rosetta what happened um the the crab
meat was on the season so a slightly
bland filling yeah i should have put
more simple a bit of bit of salt and
pepper would have just made uh made it
better okay
you still got your signature dish to
cook and you can pull it back for the
main okay okay head up okay salvos
you're in the lead yeah
long way to go now
think of it this way you've got
50 portions
of your main course to go yeah pull it
back guys yeah good luck
welcome back to the f-word now both
restaurants are going to be cooking one
of their favorite italian dishes for
their wood diners first up is salvos
[Music]
check on one pork chop seven
the recipe for salvos pork dish my ali
al alchetto is one of chip's favorite
dishes
pork is my favorite meat and it is in
fact it's the king of meads
first he cuts three medallions and
pounds them into scallops
next he chops fresh mint crushes a
garlic clove and adds white balsamic
vinegar then stirs in grilled courgettes
i can smell the garlic it's just
releasing its flavor just with the heat
of that
and places in a hot oven to soften
further
chip blackens then peels these peppers
then coats of scallops in flour and
shallow fries
i'm putting the peppers in and the
kerpers
he then adds parsley garlic thyme and
vinegar then some sugar vital to balance
the acidity now that the vinegar has
done its work
a little bit of white wine a bit of
stuff which i've got here the [ __ ]
finishes the sauce with a knob of butter
[Music]
here with my allied table five table
five coming up with my alley porky
scallops with sweet and sour peppers
served
why did you choose this dish it's got a
lot of southern roots to it and uh are
you putting color on the pork or you're
just lightly searing it and no just put
it a little colour a little colour on
the port but it doesn't want to be too
hard it's yeah it's a softer scallops
yeah good there you go your venison dish
you're using the loin
cook so quickly
uh yes now prosecco we're gonna have to
pull out all the stops for the main
course because they're four points
behind but has he got a winning dish in
that venison
[Music]
check on one venison special prosecco
signature dish is a venison fillet with
polenta and pancetta
first diego says a venison it then
flambes with gin
diego then roast it in an oven for six
to eight minutes
next polenta
in italian homes this is traditionally
cooked slowly but in a busy kitchen
diego uses a quick cooked polenta
just as delicious but cooked in minutes
not hours my grandmother would be
horrified if i were using something like
this it's like betrayal next diego fries
onions carrots and celery
then add crushed juniper berries which
complement the gin beautifully
they will give a nice gin kind of edge
to your meat diego adds a bay leaf and
some rosemary
then pours on a glass of red wine
letting it reduce before adding venison
stock
finally
the pan fries pancetta adds blanched
cabbage and crumbles in chestnuts you
have salt peppermint there's a bit of
sweetness and funny stuff with the chest
[Music]
venison fillet with polenta and pancetta
[Music]
served
you running the venison through the oven
or not yeah yeah i'll give it a pass in
the oven yeah a bit of gin juniper
flavor to the meat good why did you
choose your venison dish why because you
represent uh represents something from
the mountain it's something everybody
eats in my region
you happy with that
yeah come on do you talk to me yes
indeed i'm just looking at each one
four more by now yes
well done yeah keep them all looking
like that yes indeed sauce and
everything
thank you right now yeah you're ready
there so we make it we make it very
angle yeah good and you like the plenty
runny oh yeah i like it you know i like
it i like it too
sauce with it yeah
service please diego they look fantastic
and it smells delicious thank you thank
you thank you so much for
okay it's not a watching not a race
actually a race but it's important to
win
yeah
very very close okay
19 to 15.
what four in it
your wife yeah heidi yeah agreed to pay
yes for their dish yes yeah jim's wife
that's the bonus didn't agree to pay for
your dish now you can get it i wonder
why
yeah
jim yes did you know that your wife and
your brother refused to pay for diego
starter i didn't know that no you didn't
know that diego's wife yes paid for
yours she thought yours was delicious
ah
yeah
keep the energy
the energy is there just you know let me
use it for cooking yeah not for
conversation just watching your plate
i had the pork is really nice and tender
and i really like the mash with the kind
of crispy red peppers the courgettes
were lovely with the mint
and butter that was great
but the overriding
taste was on vinegar
and i've elected not to pay for this
dish i wouldn't pay for that there was a
lot of flavors too many flavors for me
all a little bit mixed up all a little
bit too much
the venison is beautiful and i really
really like the i think it's chestnuts
and the pancetta is really nice this
blows the pork out the water to be
honest it's a beautiful piece of meat
it's very well seasoned and excellently
cooked i'm not gonna pay for the venison
on the basis that i didn't think it was
cooked how it should have been cuts
right the pork dish from salvos with
crushed new potatoes
port's cooked perfectly moist incredibly
flavoursome
nice little sear
courgettes they managed to make a boring
courgette into something quite tasty
that is delicious however the sad news
is the sauce is just a little bit too
acidic a little bit too strong for the
pork
the venison dish
simple presentation
how's the venison cooked first off slice
it in the middle
yeah look at that perfectly cooked
well
that is harmony absolutely spot-on damn
such a shame that's just a little bit
too acidic
now time to get the diners verdict all
right well done seriously well done how
do you feel
uh excited looking forward to the
results probably one of the most intense
services i ever done all four of you
yeah exceptionally well thank you chef
and both dishes that phenomenal right
let's find out how you did uh jb please
yes okay
salvo
for your main course
those that were happy to pay
out of 50
34 out of 50. well done okay
the 16 that didn't want to play where's
the feedback
the main reason is too many 34 out of
50. well done okay thank you right
prosecco
where's that hang on this one the amount
of customers
out of 50 that are happy to pay
for your venison
40 out of 50. congratulations
[Applause]
what was the feedback on the 10 that i
didn't want to pay what was it not
enough sauce not enough sauce i'm not
very keen on the pudental i mean how can
you complain about hey
totals so far
salvo your restaurant scores 53 out of
75.
prosecco your restaurant scores 55 out
of 75. yeah you're now in front
that is tight very very tight
and it all comes down to desserts
clear down get ready for the dessert
well done guys
really well done
come on prosecco right janet's back and
she's not just brewing one animal this
time she's wearing the whole mixed grill
last year janet became a farmer for the
first time rearing two veal calves ah
stop gumming me
now i'm challenging her to raise all the
meat for the serious finale in the f
word restaurant
in total should be raising over 30
animals
it's going to be a huge challenge
first up i've sent janet to juice some
castle to provide me with some top-notch
beef and dairy but not just any cattle
i've selected dexter's
a miniature irish breed which when fully
grown are still only half the size of a
normal cow
penny hodgson is one of the uk's top
dexter farmers and should we give janet
help and advice on the breed
shetland pony turns into a cow mike just
find that you fall in love with them
janet will be taking away two pint-sized
milkers get off both come with calves
the only thing when you're milking
shortness dexters is the fact you have
to bend quite a long way
a good milking cow should have a healthy
udder and a plattered nature
ow ow
naughty girl i'm so sorry [ __ ] thing
just kicked me in the leg she is feeding
two calves and she might just think that
somebody else is sneaking in and trying
to get a little bit of milk that was
just a real one off she is i would say
one of the most plastic girls in the
whole herd here
[Laughter]
did you see that
placid woman just headbutted another
animal i like a bit of spirit
so i'm going to choose her
next i wanted to pick a couple of male
dexter's called stairs for beef
i've asked janet to choose dexter's with
good frames long backs and the
beginnings of fatty pads on their rums
that will fill out and give superb dark
richy marbled meat
are you a bit of a golden yeti yes you
are golden aren't you
how many animals is that all together in
you will have seven little dexters
the seven cows are happily loaded up for
their journey to the new home
it's the eighth cow i'm worried about as
far as i'm concerned i didn't sign up to
get kicked and
you know knocked about by them and
i think there's too many of them
but if anyone can keep this unruly bunch
in check
janet can i'm your new mum yeah
[Music]
look i'm in charge now so get over it
good to see you my darling um you look
great no it's always good to be nice to
me early on starts off that way yeah and
then it goes horribly well i've always
been taught to respect my elders it's
really good to see the pressure in the
kitchen is bigger than ever yeah but you
put me under so much pressure did you
choose the decks just because they're so
very very small just to wind me up no no
they're very small you're a giant and
they're going to know who's bust from
day one well they did kick me it's true
top notch meet for the grand final yes
look after my little cows
and don't scare them they won't be
stressed out yeah you look great not a
gray hair inside amazing
right now the recipe challenge and
tonight's challenger is katie price who
promises to eat the most delicious horse
meat sandwich if she loses oh
oh my god that's disgusting now what are
you cooking tonight well it's always
been my favorite dish chicken kiev's
sweet corn and chips but i thought i'd
do it different i'm brilliant at mashed
potato but with me it's not about
presentation it's about slapping it all
in and it tasting good so you choked in
here so i'm gonna do my version right
while we talk about it put my spuds on
and in there i'm gonna put some sugar i
always put sugar in don't ask me what i
just think it seems to taste better
sugar in the mashed potatoes yes i'm
feeling more confident already good ah
so garlic butter you'll be finished
obviously with crushed garlic a little
bit of fresh parsley and some tarragon
and then a little touch of paprika just
give it a little bit of heat god i'm not
used to this question i normally buy
already chopped don't even get anything
out of it have to squeeze really hard
can you manage
and how important is food in your life
do you think what does it mean oh i love
food i absolutely love food who does all
cooking at home who is that
well i do some and obviously we've got
nannies i'm not to lie because i'm very
strict that the kids have fresh food i
feel like i'm having any processed food
and what kind of things would you be
cooking on your own at home what would
you what would you do if it's just me
takeaways take your hurry
uh-huh
do you feel energetic after a curry no
but i do like going to bed on a full
stomach because you have the best sleep
even though it's not good for you isn't
it favorite aphrodisiac food what would
it be i haven't got one nothing in fact
people say the most if i'm sober i'm
actually i shouldn't give these secrets
away on the police show i'm better well
performed in bed when i haven't had a
drink
more phil
so that's kitchen at the moment
now you're trying to put me off my
cooking is that too much butter well
that's just i love butter don't forget
30 of it will leak out anyway so the
more the merrier
stupid thing should i do that for you
yeah still up tight
and a double knot
jesus christ
huh
right there he is that titanic yeah the
excellent good
right
now the books have sold millions yeah
from the biographies to the updates the
follow-ons have you ever actually
stopped and thought how much you're
worth i don't my brother deals with my
money only gives me pocket money each
month so how much pokemon did you get a
month what's your allowance
well my horses cost six and a half grand
a month to keep and what about for
yourself in terms of spending i'm not
high maintenance believe it or not katie
price okay
extension that's like saying i'm a
vegetarian you're not i swear
maintenance i'm not okay my hair every
three months cost 15 000 pounds that's
because i go to la and it's the flight
that costs a lot
what do they do extensions that's 60
grand a year look at the state of that
if you beat me i'm gonna be gutted you
know seriously you look you do it
properly that's a piping bag
so i can go right i'm slopping it in
down into the
center
okay it's out here
can't you
that's a proper operation i just
realized looking at your hands there
your breasts are bigger than mine
well i'm not surprised look at this [ __ ]
i put on him oh very funny not much
the chicken breast even though you've
panicked them
everyone's going to know whose is who's
honestly here honestly our blind tasters
oh yeah they're blind don't they
they're just cool blind tasters because
they don't know who's cooking what true
there flour egg wash bread crumb into a
pan lightly seared lightly colored and
then into the oven
so truthfully who's the better cook
peter or alex reed who would you say
completely different completely
different alex is more healthy oh like
complete health freak ready so alex is a
cage fighter what what was your mum's
reaction when you told her well she said
next time you go for someone make sure
they're a man's man so i showed him
their youtube
and my dad was like um bloody oh yeah he
is yeah my chicken's about to go in the
oven it may look messy but it's not
about how it looks it's how it tastes
now we've got to get on the top of the
bottom
middle have you got middle
yes oh in the middle
nice and crispy right now they have to
cook for 10 to 12 minutes then the blind
taste says we'll pick a winner there can
only be one excited
oh berry yeah i'm shaking with
excitement right now time for the
results of the recipe challenge i like
the look of those kievs if you beat me
i'm going to be so gutted you know that
huh right you come back with the right
result good luck hi everyone hello
excellent thank you
is really tender
just a rhyme
it's quite dry
for the texture of this one to that one
it's really sweet mashed potato as well
i do prefer the taste of the potato
though it is a lot more buttery right jb
what was the score it's a five to nil
five to nil
if you beat me five minutes no seriously
no no if you beat me five minutes on
this one
my crew is screwed but come on five nil
to who don't do this to me who the
winner is yes
it's you look do you know what yes
yeah thank god for that that's what the
sugar mashed potatoes go in and that's
when i started to realize i've got it
huh yeah now get out my kitchen and
don't forget this little horse sandwich
nice thanks nice to cook with you
good to see you see you take care
right now it's time for my dessert
[Music]
fig and frenzy bantas almundi luxurious
and absolutely delicious first off the
frangipane
butter icing sugar
sift
ground almonds
beet
two eggs
mix
chill
puff pastry
cut discs
[Music]
prick
smooth on frangipane
egg yolk
dust with icing sugar and now the secret
is to pre-bake the tart so it gets nice
and crispy before you put the figs on it
bake for four to five minutes
figs
slice
[Music]
bake
mascarpone icing sugar
lemon zest
mix
[Applause]
and now a nice spoon of lemon mascarpone
on top
fig and frangiban tart with lemon
mascarpone
done
salvo let's go four times away into one
please diego four tarts away on table
four please yes yes
there's only two votes in this one come
on make it count use a nice warm spoon
so it spreads out the frizzy pan on the
bottom yeah as soon as the icing sugar's
on there make sure the pastry goes
straight in the oven jim i want these
absolutely perfect jess you want too
much vinegar in your sauce that's your
fault this i want absolutely perfect
dear chip keep it going yes yes there's
only two boats in this yeah that's how
close it is jib they look beautiful
yeah
they look beautiful let's go
service please five times away on table
five yeah let's go
okay nice they look lovely come on there
you go keep the pace up let's go come on
come on come on who's going home is the
winner who's going to lose
all right there you go service please
table one yes let's go very nice
that's good
good table one
prosecco started this course really well
but unfortunately he's got a little bit
pear-shaped whereas salvos are taking it
steady but they seem to have a lot
better organization this right now is
too close to call
the tart was really fabulous
it was fresh the mascarpone was fabulous
with the lemon zest and it was lovely
this is a great dessert this one here
it's two votes that's all that's in it
we can pull this back at this stage
the pastry was quite light the figs were
spot on and the the mascarpone had a
really nice zing to it as well my
dessert's lovely really nice the puff
pastry is it's perfect very crisp so
this is beautiful okay
results
thank you
there's only two votes in this
it's all down to dessert okay
for a second
the amount of customers that are happy
to pay for the dessert is
16 out of 25 they're happy to pay for
the desserts well done
okay good
sell them if you get more than 18 out of
25 then you've won
good luck to you all
the amount of guests
that are happy to pay
for your dessert
is
it's 20 out of 25.
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations you and your restaurant
are the winners yeah really well done
yeah yes yes you're now on the
leaderboard yes yes indeed and in nine
weeks time we're gonna find out yeah who
goes through to the semi-final well done
it's been an absolute pleasure working
with all four of you now do me a favor
get out there and get a large glass a
prosecco off you go well done
salvos are number one on the leaderboard
but will their score be high enough to
earn them a place in the semi-finals of
the f-word's best local restaurant
we don't know what the next round is
going to bring but you know we're ready
for it are we crazy bring it on